Usually, we just add numbers up and take the average. This doesn't work with
frames per second. And that's the problem with 'em. If you add the 4 values
together and divide by 4, you get 27.5 frames per second. That's not correct.
however. Say we think about this question in terms of miles per hour. Instead
of 400 frames, say you drive 400 miles. If you drive 25 miles per hour for the
first 100 miles, 50 miles per hour for the next, and so on. How long will the
trip take you? Divide 400 miles by this number of hours, and you'll get your
average number of miles per hour. Using this idea, we see that the first set of
frame takes 4 seconds to view, the second; 2 seconds, third; 4 seconds, and the
fourth; 10 seconds. A total of 20 seconds. 400 frames divided by 20 seconds is
20 frames per second. This answer is a little surprising in that it's lower
than 3 of the 4 frame values mentioned. The duration of the 10 frames per
second portion of our test is so long, that it pulls the average down.